Was it the action? The writing? The side
characters? Fans who've gone to see "The
Dial of Destiny" all seem to agree
that the movie got one thing wrong.
The "Indiana Jones" franchise has returned with
its fifth and potentially final installment,
"Indiana Jones and the Dial of Destiny." The new
film is, notably, the first in the series' history
not to be directed by Steven Spielberg,
who stepped aside this time around to let
"Logan" and "Ford v. Ferrari" filmmaker James
Mangold sit in the director's chair. Despite
Spielberg's absence, "The Dial of Destiny"
does feature the return of Harrison Ford.
In the weeks since it made its premiere at the
Cannes International Film Festival, the movie
has inspired plenty of passionate responses.
Now that it's playing in theaters nationwide,
the conversations surrounding it have only
intensified, too. While the film has so far been
received fairly positively, many longtime "Indiana
Jones" fans have taken to social media to explain
why they were let down by the visual effects and
CGI featured throughout "The Dial of Destiny."
On Reddit, one fan pointed
specifically to the film's
Nazi Germany-set opening flashback, writing,
"The HORRIBLE CGI when Indy was running on
top of the train in the intro had me
shaking my head almost immediately."
In the same Reddit thread, another viewer wrote,
"Every time they went to CGI when they could
have used practical effects […]
it was a little disappointing."
Fans haven't just taken issue with the
CGI used in "Indiana Jones and the Dial
of Destiny." Viewers have also expressed
their dissatisfaction online with many of
the film's action sequences. In one
Reddit thread, a user even asked,
"I saw this on IMAX. Is it just me or were the
hand-to-hand fight sequences edited to s—?"
Their comment received numerous
passionate responses from other fans,
including one person who wrote,
"It felt so claustrophobic. Visually
it just looked wrong most of the time."
Another "Indiana Jones" fan offered their critique
of the film's various action moments, noting,
"We almost never got a chance to soak in the set
pieces because there were hardly any wide shots."
It's not hard to see why fans are going
out of their way to hold "The Dial of
Destiny" to such a high standard, either.
The first three "Indiana Jones" movies are
widely considered some of the greatest
action films that have ever been made.
*Sword moves, Indy shoots him*
Steven Spielberg's artful, exuberant
direction of them has, consequently,
been praised quite a bit over the years by
critics, casual fans, and even other filmmakers.
Of course, James Mangold also knew that
he was taking on a near-impossible task
when he agreed to helm the
film in Spielberg's place.
In an interview with IndieWire, Mangold spoke
long and admiringly of Spielberg's style
and approach to filmmaking, explaining,
"Every shot has a purpose in Steven's
work. Single-camera filmmakers who are
building sequences out of shots with a
purpose has gotten quite rare. It's all
built on a powerful connection
to the movies he grew up with."
Taking that into account, when he
finally signed on to direct "Indiana
Jones and the Dial of Destiny," Mangold
said he didn't feel any need to try to
reinvent the formula that Spielberg
had previously perfected, adding,
"I had to screw my head on to the idea that I was
essentially a pinch hitter for Babe Ruth. I didn't
feel like I had to play out some sort of rejection
of his aesthetic. I'm a profound admirer."
"You call this archaeology?"
"Get out of there, dad."
Whether or not the "Dial of Destiny" filmmaker
managed to match the quality level established
by Spielberg is something that fans will
likely spend years debating. It's also
worth noting that Spielberg's own "Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull" faced similar criticisms.
Mangold's film doesn't seem to have
been received quite as poorly as
that 2008 blockbuster. As some of
the above comments prove, though,
that doesn't mean fans don't have a lot to say
about "Indiana Jones and the Dial of Destiny."